A very warm welcome to this module on fear. False evidence appearing real. So often fear
lives in our projected future in most cases and it has a structure to it and we're going
to look at that coming up. Now particularly it's normally the perception that whatever
is we're about to experience we're going to have more negatives or downsides than positives.
There's a bit of a tip there in the structure but in this upcoming animation that we put together
once again for athletes we're going to look at the five levels of fear that you can experience.
Now this is more specifically the five meanings you can give to fear because we do have different
degrees of fear that's something else such as terror or we might have you know really strong
fear which is not quite terror we might just have some anxiety strong anxiety we might have some
just really soft low level anxiety. So you're going to have obviously a gradation or a variation
on the intensity of the fear you're feeling but then there's the relationship that you have to
what you're feeling what meaning do you give it. So that's what we're going to look at in the next
animation and then when we come back from that animation we're going to go in more depth and
unpack this thing called fear because ultimately when you transform your relationship to fear
you're going to be able to feel the fear and do it anyway you're going to be able to lean in
and grow and expand as a person as an individual and that is a good thing. So enjoy and I'll see you
when we come back.